but for the Newport East consistency
held on Thursday the 8th of June 2017
hereby give notice that the number of
votes recorded for each candidate said
election are as follows
are we about asadullahi soft silver
street opening up that we threaten
process fully launched an adult and go
back to you Dan Kastner with I can hold
without a DI we further may have in
diverland excites and a special situated
but Nevada pretty shy evoluate
transported on engages another thought
yeah defraud of relic Avenue
Nadeem are made 188 Natasha Atul Ashgar
Welsh Conservative Party candidate 12800
and 1 Peter James Brown Welsh Liberal
Democrats 966 Ian William Gorman you
Kate Wales 1180
Jessica Elizabeth Morton Welsh Labour
20,000
[Applause]
Jessica little bit more because they
were 20,000 804 Cameron Thomas
wixi by covering the party of Wales 881
and I hereby declare that said Jessica
Elizabeth Morden is duly elected as
Member of Parliament for Newport East
[Applause]
those dents can we just put place a
place there were 68 rejected benefits
will now make up an equation in Welsh as
well
now the you mermaid Council with the
with the Tasha petrushka Dave leg meal
with cancer in Peter James Brown now
canceled a declared yen Williams Gorman
in meal in comes with Dec Jessica
Elizabeth modern day that meal with
cancer pic web Cameron Thomas vixie with
councils again I couldn't that's
Canberra in water Jessica Elizabeth
Morden where the galley here for our
holiday loss in it'll just do you rank
cows near with well thank you very much
Newport ease thank you for all as we
blue voted labour in this snap general
election on all those who took part no
matter what party you voted poised a
huge huge privilege to be reelected for
the fourth time for this wonderful
constituency I look forward to going
back to work tomorrow with my team to
speak up the new pope we've got
absolutely every opportunity in
Parliament can I thank the returning
officers the counters all the staff all
the work that they've done a fantastic
ero it can't be easy and his staff can't
be easy going from a local election
straight into a general election so our
thanks to him and his staff to also
thank you to all the other candidates as
well for your the way you've conducted
this election I just finally got to say
a big huge thank you for my team in your
party led by my fantastic agent the
wonderful Deb Davis we've just grown and
grown
we have people alpha
implanted like a party for the first
time constituents who come to offer
their support and it's been absolutely
marvelous I've completely in the Newport
to bubble at this count tonight but I
look forward to seeing other results
from Welsh Labour constituencies and I
would also just like to end by saying a
very big thank you to my family and that
goes for the families of candidates
everywhere so Sean to Molly to be done
to all my family thank you very much
[Applause]